Let's say we build a graph like this. We have a structure that represents the variable x₁.
We have a structure that represents the variable x₂ and a structure that represents the variable x₃ here,
and we have a clause that say, it goes like this--x₁ or not x₂ or x₃.
And what we said with regards to the past between A and B, we said that going this way
means true and going this way means false.
So what we'll do now is we have x₁ here in this clause,
we will connect this vertex over here and over here.
What that means is that we can visit this vertex here for just one extra edge
as long as we're taking the path--that means x₁ is true.
Here, this is not right because we have not x₂, so we have to connect it in another way--
we have to connect it in exactly the reverse way because then when we take the path
that means x₂ is set to false, then not x₂ becomes true and again, in that case,
we would want to be able to visit this vertex here for just one extra edge.
Now, my question to you is--how would I have to connect this vertex here to this part here
of the graph that represents x₃.
Would I have to connect it in this way or would I have to connect it in this way.
Please check the one that is correct.